now many of you may have seen last
night's episode of the bachelorette and
i'm watching the show for the first time
ever
okay because i love a social experiment
and i want to do this collectively with
everybody i mean this is why i'm jumping
in is because i want to be with
everybody else
but i'm not totally convinced yet this
is all new to me i'm not the biggest
reality
tv person believe me i have like my
treats i ain't judging
believe me we all have our thing and
reality tv is a lot of people's thing
which is why
i want to try it too so i might need
some persuading but really i just want
to discuss it so here to change my mind
batch edition is michelle collins
[Applause]
michelle hello i missed you
hi congratulations how are you what's
going on oh my god
um everything has been so amazing so
crazy
so wonderful so wild which is you know
it's
fun it's you i feel like that's very you
you know i'm an excitable person i'm a
little crazy
i love pop culture i love human interest
i love a human mood board and that's
what the show is
well i am excited that uh you've chosen
me to teach you about the bachelor in
bachelorette because
it is something that has now been woven
in my dna i eat it i breathe it
um i have no choice i live tweet the
show well i want to teach you about
this season and you help me with reality
tv because you're a fan and i am a
newbie
so all right let's talk this season
claire crawley
yes um this is season 16. why
are people so hooked into this show well
first of all she's an ancient
39 years old and i'm also 39 so i should
add it's of my age
but they talk about it she's the oldest
bachelorette ever um and they talk about
39
which is like a baby a newborn child no
they talk about her like they
resurrected jessica tandy it's like
she's a young beautiful woman total
jessica tanner um and but they brought
these guys in that are very young now i
don't know if you've ever dated younger
the energy for a younger man to older
woman is a little different than what
the show is used to seeing
i used to like not care about age but
now i would definitely want to date
someone my age or older because i'm just
like oh please i can't go backwards
um okay so last night i was watching
um where the guys went up to her and
they literally reacted
re-enacted a cinderella tower and it's
like
oh my god you're literally perpetuating
like the fairy tale
and then the one guy that she was really
into said he choses
he chooses the hard road in life but
that really spoke to her
that did well everything kind of speaks
to her like she has an intensity about
her
i'm just being honest i like her but
she's very intense you know she really
connects
um and they spent uh the entire abc
budget to build that set as you saw i
mean it's extremely
you know they're in lockdown they don't
have a lot of choices they can only do
dates on this
in this resort that they're staying in
so i'm also not convinced that
like no one's running off with that host
because he gets an extreme amount of
screen time now here's what i really
want to do
it's spicy by the way you're so cool and
i'm thinking like let's
game this with everybody like draft you
know
what is it draft picks dream fantasy
fantasy league yes
yes let's do a fantasy league together
for bachelorette nation
so far like what are the tells how do
you think we can like
figure out like who's coming going sting
because there seems to be
a lot of drama well there are so many
men at the moment it's um truly
like costco levels there's just
everywhere you look there's guys
and at the moment they're not they
haven't really eliminated a lot of
people what they tell for this season so
far
has been this guy dale who is drop dead
gorgeous yes they've been
she said she thought her met her husband
the second she met him wouldn't you say
that if you met i would say it if i met
dale i'd be like
well it's happened to me and then a week
later i don't hear from him i'm like
oops you know but it so far it's a lot
of rumors are swirling you know i love a
swirled room well and claire was seen
like with an instagram pic that i'm like
what does the network think what does
abc think of her
showing her with like a promise ring
well she says that that promise ring is
something she gave herself like there's
all these weird things it's like
you know i don't want to get into this
woman but like her thinking in this
sense but it's a promise to herself
in some way i don't know what that's
about all right well men you know are we
out of time you're gonna have to outdo
claire for herself which i love she's
putting her first all right
thank you michelle that was so fast
thanksgiving i know let's get a draft
going let's do this everybody join in on
our social experiment with the bachelor
listen we'd be happy to give you some
roses right
you